الى خبر اخر يعطينا من مصر لا يتوقف الجدل
حول قضيه الطفل شنوده التي اثارت الراي
العام في الفتره الاخيره اخر الكلام كان
من مركز الازهر العالمي للفتوى الذي رد
بشكل قاطع للجدل شنوده مسيحي لان الاسره
التي عثرت عليه مسيحيه الازهر اوضح ان
الراي الذي يميل هو ان الطفل المتبنى اذا
وجد في كنيسه وكان الذي وجده مسيحيا فهو
على دين من وجده وكانت محكمه مصريه قد
اصدرت حكما يقضي بسحب الطفل من عائلته
المتبنى وضعي في احدى دور الرعايه مع
تغيير اسمهم شنوده ليوسف وهو ما يناقض ما
اقراه الازهر في فتواه
[موسيقى]
على كل حال كنا قبل ايام استضفنا معنا في
صباح العربيه السيده امال والده شنوده
بتبني ناشدت من خلال برنامجنا الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي وزوجته سيدا انتصار باعاده
ابنها لها متابع
عاوزه شنوده يبقى في حضني وبطلب من سياده
الرئيس
سياده الريس
سياده الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
والست انتصار السيسي ارجوكم ارجوكم اتوسل
اليكم اعتبروا شنوده ده حفيدكم اعتبروه
حفيدكم
ترجعهولي وحضرتك يا استاذ يعني يا ساتر
بالذات الريس شفت شنوده ابوه للمصريين
كلها اعتبرني اعتبرني انت ابويا رجع لي
ابن شنوده